ご視聴ありがとうございました
一応豊臣の恋人、驚異的なツキの持ち主、千葉県出身
おがんからだ
全略
ひでゆき元気でやっていますか
毎日毎日秋の空を見上げながら
お前のことを案じています
これから日に日に肌寒くなっていきます
風邪をひかぬよう十分気をつけてください
父ちゃんは年のせいか
前よりまた少し気が弱くなりました
たまにはうちに電話して
父ちゃんにお前の元気な声を聞かせてやりなさい
それでは大学の勉強を頑張ってください
かしこ母より
おがあ
ついしん大学生活は何かとお金がかかるでしょう
うちで作った梅干しと一緒に
今月はいつもより5万円多く送りました
それで何かあったかいものでも食べなさいね
おがー
どうすっかな
教科書代全部競馬ですっちまったからな
兄 おめえなんかまだ指や
俺らなんか秋だっちゅうのに着るもんがねえだぞ
見ろこれっきゃねえだよ
俺たち未だに夏服だからな
秋風が身に染みるぜやったく
とにかくこのバブル経済崩壊後の株価低迷を打開するための手段は
二つ
なんだそれは
まず第一にさらなる肯定部合の引き下げ
そしてもう一つは
豊臣銀行からの巨額融資の引き出し
これしかない
増税なき財政再編
健全なる損失補填を
おがんからの金がなかったら教科書も買えないところだったな
あの金融論と会計学
あとマーケティングソロンをください
お待ちしてました
遅かったじゃねえかよ
このパターンは
豊臣秀幸お前の立ち回り先などあらかじめ調査済みだ
おとなしく観念してお縄につき
おでかんさま勘弁してください
足は何も
いい問答無用
キリキリ引っ立て
あら
ずがー
つかー
あんだおめー
席についたそうそうつかんかや
そったらことだから勝てねーだよおめー
もっとファイト出せよ
ファイト
つかー
バカめー
ほんとはドラの山荘あんこのいいシャンテンなんだもんねー
警戒されないようにつかんふりしてんだもんねー
やんわん
ポン
お、かんちゃんずっぽし
こら、やっぱリーチ
つかーん、いいつもっちゃ
マジにつかーん
だが、まわらん
お、そんなの出るか?
論だな、リーチ一発だけ
そっち裏ドラ、高い方マンガン
なに?そんなの、ラスハイだぜ。ほら。
ラスハイのチーソーが一発で出るとは。
こら、やっぱあれかな。
ま、まさかそれは。
まさか、あの、地獄の召集ラッハと呼ばれる。
やはり、あれはカッパグ警報!
えぇ!?
カッパグそれは麻雀用語で展望を豪快にかき集めてしまうことである
多少なりとも麻雀の打てる者の間では自分がカッパグ体制に入ったと思ったときに
他の相手にあらかじめこのように警報を出すのが正しいマナーとされている
麻雀まさにそれは真のジェントルマンたちだけに許されたゲームであるといえよう
おぉ、やはりいい敗戦だ。
ダブリー!ターシュ!
ターシュ!ターシュ!
カッパギツモ!
ダブリー一発ツモ!シートイ、6000オール!
大カッパギ!
あわ!
イェーイ!
ハンチャン終わってこんなもんか。
今日は調子がイマイチだな。
おめえ、いい死にかたしねえど。
つかぁ。
テンパった。出来上がり単品三食。
出ろ。
出ろ!
リーチ!
どうしたリーチだよリーチ
おやりな
そうかどうもいい手がてんぱれると思ったら
罠だこれは巧妙な罠なんだ
こんな良い手を張らせておいて
一発でそのリーチの当たり牌を引くってわけか
なんてこった
お客さんサクサク頼みますよ
まあそう慌てなさんな
あんた?
あのパイを積もったら手を崩さなきゃならねえ運命なのさ
もういいだろう
ジタバタしやしねえぜ
ただせめてせめて
もうちっとばかし
いい夢見させておいてくれってんだよ
ごめん!泣いてねえでサクサク積もったよ!ほら!
分かったよ。
ほらな。
思った通りの当たり牌だ。
麻雀の神様は、よほど不公平がお好きらしいぜ。
まったくよ。さて、現物でも切って降りるとするか。
待って!
待って!何、おじんくさいこと言ってんのよ!
アキナちゃん!
あなた、若いんでしょ?なんでこの手で勝負しないのよ!
だって、これは過去の実績から言って、ほぼ親の当たり牌…
その弱気がおじんなのよ!
若いうちは、多少振り込んでも、取り返すという気力が必要なのよ!
それはまずい!アキナちゃん!
通せば通る!
通った
やったわ 豊臣くん
リーチです
寒い
ラン めんたんぴん一発三食
やったー
なんだ
今度はトヨタミ君がカッパグマンよ
よーしカッパギ警報
まずいいくらトヨタミでも調子に乗らせたらまずい
そくながさにゃならねえど
おんや
つもっちと
親だし、妻をドラえち、宣伝オールもらっとくか
いや、待てよ、今俺はカッパギ体制にある
こいつを切ってサブローキューピンスチーピンのフリテンリーチあるのみ
リーチ
そうだ
ダンス、ダンス、ダンス
カッパギ妻
ドタカメ大カッパギ
リーチ一発!相撲完了!三色ドラドラバンバン!
わはー!そんたら長い呪文は聞きたくねえ!聞きたくねえ!
うわーお、テンポこんなにあるよう弱っちゃったな。
しまいには血みるぞ、あれ。
もう大丈夫ね、豊臣くん。あたしゼミがあるからこれで。
バッチリした。任して。
- 任せて! うん!
やった! サプローQ1、三面町テンパイ、ドラワーG1
ここは一気にダメ押しのカッパギリーチだ!
あ、あれ? 止まっちゃったぞ
トヨタミはミスった
いくらカッパギ耐性でも、オーラス、トップ目で、ダマで上がれるときは
たとえ街が3面ちゃんだろうが100面ちゃんだろうが
絶対にリーチはない
リーチをかけても上がれそうな気がする
しかしそれは罠
それこそ絵に描いたような罠なのだ
降りだな
俺も
おら親で降りられねえだ
どうしてくんの
つもれ履いて
だめだ
あんた出ただかロンだ
メロン相手ちっといドラドラ
スーパーズガー
今度はオラの番だがや
オラオラスワンコッツムだ
ズガー
かくしてトヨタミはカッパギ修行のためビル掃除のアルバイトを始めたのだが
ほらほらもっとこせえりんだよこせ
あああんたかっぱぎがへだだな
いながさかいたほうがいいかもしねえな
ぜんりゃくかあちゃん
こずつみとどきました
かあちゃんのうめぼしたいへんおいしゅうございました
おくっていただいたおかねできょうかしょうをかいました
かあちゃんもからだにきをつけてください
とうちゃんにくれぐれもよろしくおつたいください
そしてこの手紙はついに出されることはなかったのである
あれ今何曲目だっけ
豊臣は何点ある
ちょうど1万点を割ったところか
次でトンラスだな
まったく豊臣がいると便利だな
そういうこと
なんでだ
豊臣の展望を見れば場の進み具合が分かるんだ
ほう
トン1曲手持ち2万を割る
トン二極一応一万点以上
イカトンラスで箱
オーラスでダブ箱まで
ほぼ正確に知ることができる
なるほど
ったくコンビニのやつだ
あった
ピンクドライチ
タカメタンエオの三面町だ
リーチね
チ
ほら
あぁ、いて
ごめん
Long lived
と言って
お、豊臣が箱をくぶった
何人か
L niet
Inteiko shugi
いっぱーつ!
He's coming!
Long live the party! Long live the party!
豊臣くん!豊臣くん!
あ、アキナちゃん。
やっぱりここにいたのね。
今日はどうしたの?
ねえ、今日ヨネヨネクラブのコンサートがあるんだけど、行かない?
オラは誘ってくんの!
実はオラもそのシネシネタンのファンだよ。いや、偶然でねえか。
アノクターラーさんやくさんばーだい。
なんなのよそれ!
アキナさん、悪いが豊臣はダメだ。
どうして?
豊臣は今こんなに負けている。この負け分がある限り、ここから抜け出さすわけにはいかねぇ。そういう定めなのさ、そいつは。
そうなの?でいくつ負けたんだ?あんだこら。
あんたもだいぶ千葉弁が移ってきたな。
マイナ120だ?
よし、オラが取り返してやるだよ。おめぇはそこどいてろ。
そこどいてろ。
馬鹿な女だ。
こないだちょっと馬鹿しついてたもんで、
頭に乗り上がって。
俺たち相手に、
二連勝できっとでも思ってんのかよ。
ところで、
アキナさんが負けたら、
別に金や物で負け分を払ってくれなくてもいいんだぜ。
だんだん?
そりゃ何かい。
体で払うってことかい。
え?
ヤス。
声が高い。
兄しゃべくってんだ。
サクサクやっと!サクサク!
あら、なかなかいい手!
あ、それち!
いい手で、りゃんめんち!
本逸か?
すっぴん!
いや、本逸でちいそうはあんなに早く切らない。
なんは俺があんこだし、
ただのタンヤを3食だけじゃん。
暗闇の町は、ズバリ、寒三品。
こっちだ!
あれ、当たれる?
どひこめ。
じゃ、上がっとこ。なんぼ?
小三軒だけ、おやまん。
あんだ?おめえ一回待てば、初積もってたでねえか。
え?うそ?
俺が三品切ってりゃ、一万六千ウォール引かれてたのかよ。
ああ見逃せばよかった
豊臣くんのバカバカバカバカバカバカバカバカ
恐ろしい月だ
やっぱ女は勝負強さがねえな
冗談じゃねえぞ
これはうかうかしてと
こないだの二の舞だぜ
サクサク流す
あ、それちょっと待って
まさか
えっと
そのパイの動きは
タテチン、ハネマン、ドヒコメ
よーし、ちいといドラドラテンパッタドー
早見を狙い撃ちすっぺ
あの捨て牌からすっとパーピンの方が出そうだっぺ
アマンダー?やっぱりダンソーの方だった
な、なら絶対デッドー!
アンダー!
こっちにすっか。
や、やがてよ。
オラ、もう絶対買えねえど!
やった!
アンダーキューだよ!
ドラ、あんこってまたでねえか!
ドタさんめ ピーフランペーカーをドラドラ
パンツー人生だべ オラの人生を
旅の人をどうしなすっただね
運にも月にも見放され
オラにはもう夢も希望もなくなっちまっただよ
海見るだ
男はそったらとき海見据えて
自分を海にさらけ出してみるだよ
オラこれから思い出の中に生きていくだよ
万中攻撃だ
俺たちをじわじわと追い詰め
極限状態に陥ったところを
完膚なきまでに打ちのめす
しかもそれを全く自覚していない
なんというバカ好き女
いやーまいった
結局6万点も勝っちゃったんだ
もうチャラでよかったのに
もうこの秋名ちゃんの強がりさ
やあ豊臣くん
スーパーズガン
はーいお客さん負けたことはサクサク認めてください
サクッとね
ねえ トヨタミ君 せっかく逆転勝ちしたんだから
お祝いに何かおいしいもん食べに行こうね
じゃあね 寿司にステーキにスペイン料理
やだ そんなに食べられるわけないじゃない
それもそうだね
でも その前にコンサート
うん
くそ 許さねえ
こったらごと絶対に許さねえ
長かった暗黒の時代を駆け抜け
ようやく人並みの幸せをつかみ取った豊臣
その心は秋の空のように晴れやかだった
しかし案の定その幸せは
そう長くは続かなかったのである
一句
当たり牌
集めて林
ダブル箱
おそ松
もう、秋も終わりに近づいて、なんばのラスマイってとこかしら。
今年一年、月のなかったあなた。
起死回生の酷使無双、天罰ってる?
次回、スーパーズガン!
君は完璧さ!パート1、パート2
きっと見てね!
眠っちゃいや!
インターネットスター・スターズ・ミナミ・ハローホール!
勝負かけたら花咲を呼ぶのが大愚痴
君はアゲマント主席じゃないか
僕とワンカウントフォローよ
使うと幸せつかもうぞ
ここは三面に待ちどころ
行くぞカンキャン 腹渋底の責任が破断
2号2号は健康にやりぬいて
勝手飲み越すビールがうまい
スカット オタカワイドチガケ
スカット スカット ガキカメタ
アラララララ
ご視聴ありがとうございました